Deadwood the movie is finally here it
has finally arrived and it airs on HBO
Friday May 31st at 8:00 Eastern Time and
the man who plays Seth Bullock
Timothy Olaf at back here on the show
how are you sir great good to be here
and before I say another word you sent
me the nicest message after you saw the
movie and it really meant the world well
I meant it it is perfect Timothy it is
nothing argue with you it is perfect
again and I'll repeat you know what I
just wanted to make sure you knew before
you came on here and what I told fans of
this show and when Deadwood that it's so
rare to have a dream come true of one of
your favorite shows get the extra shows
or picked up again or a movie that we
needed to tie stuff up it's so rare for
that to happen period mm-hmm ever mm-hmm
and then for it to reach every level of
expectation in terms of the spirit
language acting look sound feel that's
what this is Matt congratulations that's
really really what it is and it's funny
how many times you've been on this show
and we've talked about your projects
that you were working on at the moment
on my go which you pretended to care
about I did which meant a lot to me that
also by the way let me say two things
one just appreciate your message after
you saw the deadwood movie yes you're
genuine message I've never said that to
you before I also want to thank you for
all the fake compliments you've given me
in the year soon no no no you know I've
enjoy everything that you've done
including the fan of Mother's Day live
free or die hard a big fan of live free
or die hard girl-next-door okay thank
you yeah did you just you the man point
over that Phil my buddy Tim remember
call back to Monday at Rich's house so
it was I think it was the last time or
two times where you're on and you you
you when I ask the same question over
and over again where you were kind of
putting up the level of expectation
lowering my expectation of all of the
Deadwood movie ever happening time you
were on early I know
you were giving me no reason for it to
have happened the last time you were on
about a year ago how did this come
together Timothy how long ago how much I
mean the short answer is you know David
wrote a script and we were all we were
we were available I mean I is really not
a lot more mystery to it than that I
don't know and it was a good script it's
amazing it happened right I mean I think
that I experience my experience reading
it similar to the experience you just
showed that clip of scene with did with
Dayton Callie and I have this experience
watching that clip that I think you
probably share as soon as Dayton comes
on the screen I think oh I just love
that guy I just loved I mean I have a
personal relationship with him I loved
working with him all those years ago all
these memories come right back but then
there's a character that's attached to
it to him that I just loved that
character Charley other than it Chuck
just loved it
I just loved him and and feel like I
know him at such a bizarre intimacy that
you have with these characters from that
show because they were all so richly
drawn there's a there's a moment in in
that scene there where I mentioned not
all saloon mm-hmm I remember Tom Nuttall
I remember the saloon owner I remember
how wonderful that character was just
the mention of his name you're like oh
my god not all just love that well my
wife and I sighs I emailed you I said
they it felt like we were revisiting old
friends and I said it's just a testament
to David Milch and his work I've never
seen a I never when when the show was on
the air I had never seen anything like
it and I've never seen anything like it
since and when I've never seen something
that seven eight nine ten characters
deep each one of them is they should
have their own show you just think I
love that I love that character I know
that character so intimately it's such a
rich experience David doesn't know how
to write any other way
there's a moment in the movie I don't
know if you noticed there's a moment in
the movie where basically an extra mob
forms and threatening violence and
there's a moment where one of the mob
people in the crowd yells I hope you die
in the street like my dad did I always
thought I remember thinking you know any
other writer would have just written I
hope you die in the street mm-hmm Mill
chatted like my dad did he added like a
backstory in just a few words remember
you just kind of go ate what's his deal
are we gonna get to know him too because
he's got a whole background he's got a
whole story right that's amazing it is
it it truly is and you know like I said
just to see it all
materialized once again why did it end
I've never really I don't know yes who
knows you know do you is there a story
you just don't want to go down that road
I mean I know some of the stories I mean
I think there's more than one I mean I
think it takes a couple people to make
an accident but you know I don't know
you know it was a bit of a mess I think
that Mills had a and I'm not sure it's
that entertaining story so you just
stopped me somebody stop me it's only
milk sure I think he had a deal with
Paramount I think the show was crazy
expensive no look I was I cried when I
cried when Reggie Jackson left the
Yankees okay I was a I was a let me get
this right 11 year old kid not
understanding why Reggie Jackson had to
leave the Yankees yeah but somebody sat
me down and stir well you know what
there's the owner and he was making a
lot more money
sure could make a lot more money he
thought he was worth all very similar to
that story there is a business side of
things that you know I think you know
David called me in the morning and said
we're done you know I just bought a
house and stories out there I bought a
house we just renegotiated my deal they
gave me a big raise they gave me Shane a
big ray
I don't think there was any intention of
the show being canceled there was no
reason to give us a raise if they're
right and they wouldn't you know they
foolishly gave us a bunch of money and
then canceled the show you know what he
explained to me that morning is he felt
like he was getting the nudge and when
someone gives you a nudge it better to
walk away and I said okay you know I
imagine he's I figured he was exhausted
and needed a break well I mean and it is
because it's such a deep show and it's
it's I don't know how he did it for
three years it was he literally running
he was seen before you were doing it and
handing you a page and you gotta learn
that I am back picked that that filthy I
am banned tab off the top of your head
pencil are you serious dialogue and
pencil couldn't stop himself the problem
was never you know he just can't stop
himself he was forced to be reckoned
with and I've never seen anything like
it
and ruined to me for you know ruined me
going forward
I mean ruined me for other for people
other writers I see what you're saying
yeah cuz I'd say we could this could we
could reread rewrite this but this could
get better and they're like we're
shooting it in an hour and I was like
yeah I've seen it I've seen it this is
totally doable right somebody get me a
pencil yeah and then not so much so fond
of that process Timothy Olyphant here on
the Rich Eisen show and like I said it's
just it's just terrific I'm so glad to
to see it all again what in the sports
world is leaping out at you in the
middle of anything right now well do you
think why are we all talking about the
French Open I mean we're playing we're
playing tennis you're a tennis guy just
love it you are huh oh my god what's
your game do you play I do yeah
okay and yeah what are we strong okay do
you play a little tennis I try I commit
it and I'm not very good no actually I
will tell you this that one shot I can
really do well yeah and I'm serious he's
on the run for hand running for an
cross-court Oh on the run really I
wouldn't say it's just I wouldn't say
it's Federer like I wouldn't even say
it's fed like generous it's it's F like
it's like like I've got I've got maybe
like a 1/100 of a Federer uh-huh you
know what I mean that your strings hit
the ball in that respect it's similar no
no the word to describe it uncork oh you
want right on Corky oh you know I mean
like I've got the open hand let's just
talk through that part because I think
we can help you stop ok ok yeah
yes let's just let's just give it a
little more hair yeah ok she was about
to happen there you're about to get no
no you're not gonna lift it okay you're
gonna brush it switch on your mind
I heard the topics today college college
basketball or yeah or go play in New
Zealand what would you do you gotta go
through the walkabout I really yeah go
get paid get paid okay oh yeah don't get
me started on these college NCUA's come
on that system is broken in it oh I
would I would agree
oh my god it's broken I would agree how
do we how do we get organized I think we
get organized I think we break that
system I think we'd let the kids if they
can make money off their own name oh my
god oh my for sure go for it
oh for sure anybody in and what that
means is even are we breaking the system
now here's the Saturday maybe do we have
time for this we do I cuz I you can
lighten me here I don't want to break
college sports I love college sports I
swam in college
love it but the system is that what's
going on there that people are getting
well I mean I messed up sis it's a
messed up system Timothy Olyphant here
in the Richard show I think if you let
kids make money off their own likeness
we're good I think some kids might not
be able to and some will be able to what
about just making money off their sport
well for example here's where it really
gets me cuz I get that the rules seem to
be designed for the big sports college
football for the college and for the
coaches and it's basically just a farm
system two professional leagues they say
they're giving a free education they're
not even really doing that all right but
here's where I really there's where it
really gets me well we'll talk tennis
for a second the fact that some kid at
USC cannot during the summer months yes
go out and make as much money as he can
playing professional tennis hmm while
he's at college athlete makes no sense
to me swimming yes there's very little
opportunity to make a lot of money and
caught and swimming every kid still
wants to be a college swimmer it's still
the big dream but the Olympics come
around and kids have an opportunity to
cash in and they have to make a choice
be going you like if it's a high school
girl who's a phenomenal Olympic athlete
she has to make a choice between being a
professional going professional and
being on the cover of Wheaties or
swimming in college it seems moronic to
me that that choice is even having to be
made well I agree with you on all of
that here's how things you like the
deadwood movie is and pretended to like
all my other stuff and I can uncork I
knew I liked to cross court forehand
sweeping show me that sweet tell me that
a little much but still you see where
it's going these guys come on we're
going here this here elbows up and then
we're getting good good see that oh
we're gonna an extend yes extend extend
you were doing this kind like here I
come I'm sitting I wasn't expecting to
do it is the lights were in my eyes
interesting haven't eaten if you want to
get up and for I think we have times you
want to get out
I can show us I'm sure I don't know I
mean you're the one who said here's the
thing I can do well I'm running in terms
of tennis in terms of ten I didn't say
out of all the things physically that I
can no I know and I we were all with you
but then when you started to do the the
visual then we thought oh he's making
this up no I I can do it okay
seen it I can on you seen it to go three
years ago when I was a much younger man
it's more spry okay when is more spry
when I had only a dream of the deadwood
movie from happening and now it's
happened now always happen once upon a
time in a Hollywood you're on you're in
that is well right so now I can there to
this looks amazing
yeah that's that's my I've not seen it
no okay no but because that was uncorked
I'm pretty hon Film Festival it was nice
right thank you yeah but your role in it
I can't remember what I'm supposed to
tell you or not tell you I say this
sincerely yes I encourage you to not
find out anything about the movie and I
would encourage any of you or listeners
or viewers just do the same there are
very few occasions where there's things
worthy of not wanting to know anything
about it and just go in yes just trust
me it's going to be you know the it's
going to be a special special story it's
gonna be something special and you're
not you just don't want to know anything
about it okay I do know you're supposed
to ask questions that's my job my job is
to say tell people here I'm here I'm
here to offer you some some very
important advice okay you don't want to
know anything about nothing about the
Tarantino no you're just gonna go
what about times you know itself what do
you wanna know on the night of fan on
the crazy meter Milch or him who's
higher Oh on the crazy meter oh no no no
that's that's an unfair look
that's good good good huh
on the crazy meter yeah no no they're
both fully centric meter listen yes
we're talking about forces of nature
yes major forces me that's fully
committed okay and this is what we love
this is what we love about them it's
true they're both showing you a way to
do things that you had not had never
occurred to you was even possible
they're creating the the example I gave
with milk writing and pencil and me
going to other shows and say no we could
you know we can fix this you know you
can't that and you're like no I've seen
it I've seen it I've seen it done
Quinton is a a similar animal he's he's
he's his set is a set unlike anything
I've ever been on there is he's
operating by a set of rules that he's
you know that you just I've never seen
on any other set and likewise I've gone
to other sets since being on that one DA
like a total what's ours we're not
swearing on this if you want to stay
fries and overtime like you know like
rhymes would tick I do we just went in
like a total rhymes with tech and said
hey guys how about no cell phones on the
set and there I was like no I've seen it
Quentin he's got no cell phones allowed
are you serious no cell phones a lot
about that none you fired really fired
no kidding cellphone out done no warning
nothing you're going home I'm not
telling tales outside this is what it is
but you're aware of that going in right
you're told that's the there's a outside
the set mmm we'd be like here on our
lovely little set yes we would have a
little booth outside out there on East
Douglas
a little booth over there yeah
for everyone to check their phones in
and that's where all your all our phones
would be out there on the on Douglas
Street if you needed to make a phone
call you go out to the street you make
phone call now is that for to remain
focused or to make sure that nobody's
sneaking any any shots all the hosting
it no I I don't think it has anything to
do with people filming or taking
pictures I think it's about creating an
environment where while we're all here
making this thing that's what we're all
gonna do we're gonna make this thing
we're not gonna be we're not going to be
over there doing some other thing
instagramming or or you know working on
your next script or talking to your
agent know we're here and this is what
we're doing and we're gonna take it
really seriously we're gonna have a the
most fun taking this job so everyone's
in it and I I I don't know how it comes
across it was one of the greatest gifts
that I think he gave the that he gives
the entire I feel like and all the
actors I could see how it creates an
environment that is unique it's in the
deadwood movie notes talks about it
actually now that I mention it there's a
the telephone is coming to this write to
Deadwood yes right and swear engines got
a monologue that talks about every man
worth his salt right knows the value of
being unreachable right to to be able to
shut it down it's in the movie he's
talking about the same thing I'm talking
about this is where these two men are
alike they both appreciate and the value
of not being interrupted which by where
are we on the swearing thing yes you can
CBS yeah you don't want to be you don't
want the BS involved and so both those
men have been lucky enough to be around
and work with this environment I know
you're not on social media
Timothy so what if there was a sound
person on the show or the movie set who
wasn't paying attention like right now
because he was on a Twitter
Twitter account a Twitter account
dedicated to a pug named Doug yeah I
love Doug the pug so he would if this
was Tarantino rules and the Rich Eisen
Show set he would be [ __ ] he fired I was
there one day with phone went off my
phone went off yeah was the back in the
who's back in the it's like a block down
all of a sudden we were all talking
we're all in it phone went off oh man it
was scary somebody just took off running
took off it was it was wonderful and I
mean it says it's just I have to tell
you it was like that is one of them I
could go all day about what it's like to
work with the man
but that is one thing where he is he's
decided to march to the beat of his own
drum to say no on this set that's we
just don't we I don't care what's going
on out and everywhere else in the world
on this set we're here we're making this
movie he loves making movies it's clear
in his in his work for short can you
stick around or do you have to run out
of here I'm unemployed okay that's
fantastic that's great news
Timothy Olyphant is gonna finish up the
show and maybe we'll twist your arm to
certainly to go on Eisen over time when
you can use whatever language is freely
oh yeah that's exciting
that's very good so Timothy all event
still here on the Rich Eisen show when
we wrap this show up in a second one
more segment here you got about three
minutes to go out to you see you're too
late on the drop where you doing Doug
the pug right there with the music
coming back in Mike you're good I'm good
see Tarantino would have his ass on the
street Mike I'm sorry but it's true
well good if you're lucky I'm not
Quentin Tarantino I mean you guys are
well one last segment here with Timothy
Olyphant here on the Rich Eisen show so
here's how it's gonna work if you don't
mind we got about two minutes and change
to close up this show okay then we say
again map this out map this out and then
we've got a segment just for our app :
isin overtime it's very popular segment
you can talk okay certainly more popular
when you're on it you could talk you
could say whatever you want on that
segment I can't don't do it no filters a
script
oh yeah good idea okay good yeah well
good well by the way
just say this right now if you haven't
got the app get the app because it's
gonna be wise this is completely gonna
be amazing
we've just mapped something out and you
won't be able to get to the end of the
it's going to be amazing now you said
you said coming back from break here
that you teared up at the end of reading
once upon a time and I did okay well
Terry did you tear I was quite moved at
the end of the Deadwood movie as well
did you tear up there - yes very I was
very moved I'm and I'm just watching it
we went to the premiere did you I didn't
get that invite no I just got a link
nobody at the end did you get be honest
we did yeah just saying this like I said
it to you about it is perfect from the
first note to the end thank you I'm very
very very proud of it very I mean they
should be it's so great it's so rare
that that fans of a show get to be
treated for one last time it is one last
time right we're not going to equal
draft breeze from that billionaires
thing doesn't exist without David Milch
and I think I think as well I know it's
a very proper ending while it is
bittersweet
amazing though beginning to end and
that's the end of this program I want to
thank Reggie Bush also Jeff Van Gundy
for being on the show tomorrow Christian
Yelich our defending national league
Most Valuable Player will be on the
program he's good on Friday show looks
like not only do we have new Michigan
basketball coach from the Fab five Juwan
Howard
oh that's cool we might get Jalen - yeah
oh I'm a big fan of those guys
two-fifths of the Fab five that's pretty
good
and Jay Williams also from ESPN that's
how it rolling on the rest of this show
that's right what is that next week
that's Noah's Friday that's Friday
Deadwood movie comes out come back come
back come back
Timothy know too much to ask that you
just talked to those talked to those
guys about Deadwood we're just gonna go
see on the air
Jalen was talking Deadwood oh my god
that make my day I don't get me wrong I
got a lot of good things happening on
Friday but is it too much bass for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app